Você abre seu aplicativo no Nubank, vê a conta corrente descendo um pouco mais, tem a
parte de cartão de crédito. No máximo você utiliza, clicando aqui no cifrão, as caixinhas
para guardar um dinheirinho. Hoje o Nubank tem 112 milhões de clientes e a grande maioria
faz assim como você. Não entendem que existem outras possibilidades de investimento, até
mais lucrativos dentro do aplicativo e se limitam somente a conta corrente, cartão de crédito e a
caixinha. Porém nesse vídeo estamos com mil reais na conta e vamos investir na prática com vocês.
Vai ter renda fixa, eu vou emprestar dinheiro a juros, fundos imobiliários, vou me tornar dono,
de móveis aqui no Brasil, ações brasileiras, eu vou virar um grande magnata, dono de empresa,
investimentos no exterior, empresas americanas, as maiores do mundo e por fim também Bitcoin,
tiramos dinheiro de todo o governo possível. Para mostrar que mesmo que com pouco você já consegue
ter uma carteira diversificada. Vamos pegar agora 300 reais, ou seja 30% desses mil e emprestar a
juros, porém sem ser a jota. Então muitas pessoas já estão acostumadas, clica aqui no cifrão,
vem aqui nas caixinhas, clica para criar uma nova caixinha, coloca qualquer coisa que seja,
que vou viajar, guardar um dinheiro para trocar de telefone, ai vem aqui a eu quero colocar
os 300 reais que vai ser aqui desse vídeo. Porém não entendo de fato qual o funcionamento por
trás dessa caixinha, simplesmente clica em confirmar o dinheiro já está aqui dentro. A caixinha
é de um RDB Recibo de Depósito bancário, onde eu impresso o dinheiro para o Nubank e recebo
juros por isso. O banco ganha dinheiro utilizando a receita dos clientes que eles colocam aqui na
conta na caixinha, emprestando a outras pessoas a juros maiores. É o famoso spread bancário,
o grande motor do lucro dos bancos aqui no Brasil. Então hoje no bank vai empagar 100% no CDI,
é sempre 0,10 pontos a menos, que é a taxa básica de juros aqui no Brasil, que é a CDI,
ou seja CDI 14,75% ao ano, CDI 14,65% vai dar pouco mais de 1% ao mês. Aí eles vão pegar o seu
dinheirinho e emprestar para outra pessoa, porém a juros muito maiores, então temos aqui o
camarada, o camarada que pega 30 mil reais vai pagar 48 vezes de 3.422, que é uma taxa de juros
aproximada de 10,95% ao mês, ou seja ele te paga um e cobra 10% para o outro. E qual que é o risco de
eu botar meu dinheiro na caixinha, de eu emprestar o meu dinheiro para o Nubank? E é muito simples,
o risco de você não receber é no caso do Nubank quebrar. Hoje no bank já é um dos bancos mais
mais viva aqui do Brasil, porém ainda por cima disso existe a garantia do FGC, fundo garantidor
de crédito, então mesmo que o banco que você empresteu dinheiro venha a quebrar, ele te ressarce
até 250 mil por CPF, até 1 milhão em 4 anos caso vários bancos quebrem ao mesmo tempo. E é muito
simples, aqui nós temos um RDB resgate imediato, eu vou poder sacar a qualquer momento, inclusive
de madrugada, que teve caso já de amigo de amigo nosso, e é realmente que o nosso amigo contou a
história do amigo dele, que estava lá em uma casa noturna de madrugada, uma senhorita via lhe
prestar num serviço, ele tinha que pagar o serviço, o guarda-acosta da senhorita estava ao lado,
vamo com o cafetão, eu to falando de uma forma para não ficar chulo, se ele não pagasse o caudinho
ele foi querer sacar o caudinho da caixinha, era RDB de resgate diário, ou seja, ele não conseguiu
resgatar na hora, porém o empréstimo ele conseguiu pegar, conseguiu pagar e saiu ileso daquela situação.
E agora nós vamos virar grandes magnatas do setor imobiliário, investindo em múltiplas propriedades
ao mesmo tempo, tudo isso através da bolsa de valores aqui do Brasil, através dos fundos
imobiliários. O mundo imobiliário é uma forma de você investir em imóveis, sem precisar comprar
um salto inteiro, então ao invés de comprar um apartamento, uma sala comercial, uma casa que
vai custar muito caro, hoje em dia essa é a realidade, em 2026 você vai comprar uma kitnet 30m²
e vai pagar 200 mil e você pode ver que nem separar da sala do quarto é, porém, para você
investir em fundos imobiliários é possível começar com muito menos, o que mais me indigna é ter
que pagar 332 por mês de PtU, por exemplo, o XP ML11 hoje com 110,66 a.C. você compra uma cota e ele
te pagou em dividendo no último mês 92 centavos e nessa hora muitas pessoas se perguntam, mas de
onde vem esse dividendo que é pago pra você e é muito simples, então aqui nós temos o relatório
e o XP ML11 é dono de vários shoppings espalhados em todo o Brasil, então eles tem uma parte do
shopping cidade de Ardim, aquele dos magnatas, aquele que tem somente loja de grifes, aquele que você
que está a pé nem consegue entrar, inclusive tem até vídeo no comecinho do canal que nós visitamos
shoppings aí de fundos imobiliários, tem cidade de São Paulo que é lá na paulista, esse aqui nós
já fomos também, TET Plaza Shopping, shops de Ardinhas, vocês podem ver que eles tem muitos
mais pelo Brasil e vão adquirir ainda mais, eles são donos desses shoppings, esses shoppings
possuem lojas que podem ser alugadas, quem vai lá e pega uma loja de alugas tem que pagar aluguel ao
dono da loja que no caso é o fundo mobiliário, você comprando uma cota se torna proprietário de
parte desses imóveis, obviamente que de forma indireta e por ser dono também você recebe a sua
coitinha através dos dividendos, porém tem o seguinte, que esse fundo mobiliário tem um total
de 704 mil cotistas, ou seja você vai ser dono com mais 700 mil pessoas, ele tem um total de 58
milhões de cotas, você está comprando uma das 58 milhões de cotas e é por conta disso que com
pouco dinheiro você já consegue comprar uma cota, já consegue se tornar sócio, já consegue receber
um dividendo todos os meses, nessa hora é muito esquechoso, se eu comprar uma cota é só uma vez
eu receber esse dividendo pra sempre ou eu tenho que continuar comprando todos os meses, nessa hora é
muito simples, você comprando uma cota de 110 reais, a cota é sua, todo mês quando ele paga
dividendo você vai receber, porém tem o seguinte, que somente com uma cota você vai receber por
mês alguns centavinhos, então eu tenho uma cota todo mês e eu recebo 92 centavos, isso aqui mudou
a sua vida, para você conseguir receber cada vez mais dividendos você tem que ter cada vez mais cotas
vamos comprar uma cota na prática com vocês, então eu venho aqui no aplicativo em cima em
investir, eu arrasto para o lado e temos fundos imobiliários, eu escrevo aqui xpml11, já vai
aparecer para eu comprar, cliquei aqui em cima, comprar, eu vou comprar a mercado, ou seja o preço
vou pagar uma cota e aqui a interface tá complicada, porque já aparecia um, meio que aqui só que eu
tenho que apertar o botão, clico em comprar, já aparece aqui o preço da cota, ele pega uma
reservinha aqui para executar ordem e a taxa da bosta 4 centavos, clico aqui em comprar e já parece
que a ordem foi executada, eu paguei 110 reais com 83 centavos, vamos agora investir em outro fundo
imobiliário, dessa vez o HGCR11, uma cota está custando 97,50 reais, no último mês ele pagou por
cota 95 centavos em dividendos, porém esse daqui não tem nenhum imóvel, nessa hora você se pergunta
como assim porque que eu vou investir em um fundo imobiliário que não tem imóvel, é muito simples
ele é um fundo imobiliário de papel, ele empresta dinheiro para o setor imobiliário, esse juro que ele
distribui em dividendos, e você tem uma cota, é dona de parte desse fundo recebe a sua parte
através dos dividendos, e aqui vocês podem ver para quem ele empresta dinheiro, então empresta para
o Almeida Julho, ele empresta para Globo, empresta para o Açaí, empresta para o Carrefour, nós temos
a taxa que ele está cobrando, os devedores pagam para ele, ele paga para você, e por ser um fundo de
imóvel, cobrar juros, ele costuma pagar um dividendo maior comparado aos fundos de tijolo, porém o
potencial de valorização acaba sendo menor, porque os imóveis no longo prazo primeiramente
o aluguel é ajustado todo ano, todo ano chega o reajuste do aluguel, ou pelo IGPM ou pelo IPCA,
ao longo do tempo a tendência é dos imóveis se valorizarem, logo no longo prazo a tendência
das cotas subirem, já no fundo de papel a dinâmica não é da mesma forma, porque são dívidas ele empresta
e quando acabou a dívida ele vai pegar o dinheiro e alocar em outra, vai emprestar para outra
empresa e as dívidas não valorizam, então vamos lá, HGCR11 aparecendo, clico para comprar,
uma cota, preço de mercado mesmo, ordem já enviada, agora tenho dois fundos mobiliários na carteira
para pagar dividendos todo mês, e esse vídeo é para o pessoal que está começando investindo
apenas mil reais, porém sabemos que temos muitos seguidores que já tem mais dinheiro, que já investem
por que tem 100, 300, 500, 1 milhão, mas muitas vezes na correria do dia a dia é trabalho, é família,
não conseguem dar atenção devida a carteira de investimentos, não conseguem ter clareza,
será que eu estou no caminho certo ou não, aí liga o assessor da corretora então, eu estou aqui
com uma baita oportunidade para você investir, porém ele está mais interessado nas suas comissões,
no interesse dele do que de fato em crescer o seu patrimônio, tanto que chegou o cliente
na nossa consultoria, mas de 3 milhões de reais investidos com esse tipo de produto.
O cliente grande vindo aí de uma corretora da assessoria quanto que ele perdeu em dinheiro nesse
tempo?
O Gregor, calculando aqui, ainda tem muita coisa para calcular, mas mais de 114 mil reais que ele
deixou de ganhar por conta de uma falta de estrutura e planejamento adequado na carteira.
Ou seja, um cuide e meio aí praticamente.
Exatamente.
Legal, fala mais para a gente aí.
Legal, então citando aqui dois exemplos, por exemplo, dois quais que ele tem na carteira,
o XP Uro com a alta limitada e o XP Dragões Azeares.
O XP Uro limitou a alta que ele poderia ter com 100%, a comodidade desde o momento que
ele aplicou o recurso, ela subiu 260%, ou seja, ele deixou de ganhar ali por ter um ativo
mais líquido, mais de 40 mil reais, só nessa aplicação.
Só em uma?
Se a gente faz ali para XP Dragões Azeares, ficou praticamente no 0 a 0, esse CoI, desde
ali de 2020.
Se ele tivesse aplicado na CELIC, ele teria 16 mil reais a mais.
Ah, não perdi nada, então fui lá, coloquei, está no 0 a 0, porém de 2020 até aqui,
somente deixando o tesouro direto, somente deixando em um CDB, já teria rendido e rendido
muito.
Fora?
Ah, coloquei 100 mil reais lá em 2020, que o poder de compra que você tinha lá era um,
mas tem os mesmos 100 mil hoje, o poder de compra é muito menor.
Então para esse vídeo aqui, para você que tem pelo menos 100 mil reais investidos, vai
ter o link da descrição, comentário fixado também, QR Code aqui na tela, que o Hia vai
colocar para quem está assistindo da TV, escanear e entrar nesse site aqui da DineCaptor,
onde você vai preencher os seus dados e vamos disponibilizar 10 vagas para esse vídeo aqui,
para um constor nessa equipe, analisar a sua carteira sem compromisso, ver se está bacana,
ele vai comentar o que está certo, e fazendo sentido ao final da reunião, você pode entrar
para a nossa constoria, além de virar um grande magnata do Ramo imobiliário, que para
mim magnata é o cara que tem muito dinheiro, porém também entendo o seguinte, que hoje
você começa com um pouco aqui, você vai comprando mais cotas ao longo dos meses,
vai reinvestindo hoje dividendos, que aí de fato, no futuro você pode sim virar um
grande magnata, agora vamos investir em grandes empresas, nos tornar sócios das maiores empresas
do Brasil através das ações na Bolsa de Valores, então ação é uma pequena parte de uma empresa
gigantesca, e está na Bolsa de Valores, quando você compra uma ação que seja, vira dono de uma
pequena parte dessa empresa, e quando ela distribui lucro aos sócios, você recebe a sua parte através
das tendas, e uma das empresas que vamos investir aqui vai ser BB Seguridade, empresa de seguros
do Banco do Brasil, uma ação hoje custa R$33,92 e pagou nos últimos 12 meses em dividendos 4,54,
e muito importante, esse setor de seguros é extremamente seguro e previsível aqui no
Brasil, então no caso da B Seguridade, o maior foco dela é em seguro do agronegócio, porém o
que os mais conhecem é o seguro do automóvel, e aí é muito simples, você vai lá, paga o seguro
todo ano do seu carro com a intenção de não usar, você paga a torcida, espero que não bata o carro,
espero que não aconteça nada, espero que não deixente, espero que o tomador de cervejinha não
leve meu carro embora para eu continuar tranquilo, porém caso aconteça alguma coisa, a seguradora
vai lá, e paga, caso não aconteça, você paga pelo seguro antes, esse dinheiro ficou no cátia da
seguradora, rendendo hoje uma Celiq muito alta quase 15% ao ano, e o quanto eles cobram no seguro
varia de acordo com o perfil do cliente, então você pega o mesmo carro, um Audi conversível,
Audi TT, se for um jovem de 23 anos, o preço do seguro vai ser muito mais caro, não precisa falar,
agora se for esse mesmo carro, porém para o pai de família, casado, três filhos, mulher, vai usar o
mesmo carro enquanto que a conversiva, 50 anos, está realizando o sonho da juventude, o seguro vai
ser bem mais barato, mesmo que seja exatamente o mesmo carro, então vamos aqui no roxinho, ainda
tenho R$ 491,61, é muito importante, que esse vídeo aqui não é uma recomendação de investimentos,
então nós estamos aqui investindo na prática, e te mostrando possibilidades, dá para investir na
renda fixa, dá para investir em infos mobiliários, porém na hora de você investir, entendo o seguinte,
você precisa estudar, entender no que você está investindo, e fundos mobiliários e ações que
estamos mostrando aqui, são ativos de renda variável, então o preço da cota ou da ação varia,
de acordo com a demanda compradora e vendedora, e o quanto você recebe em dividendos também
varia, de acordo com o resultado da empresa, de acordo com o resultado com o lucro do fundo
mobiliário, vamos agora para essa área, ações brasileiras, engraçado que ele bota aqui embaixo
e que potencial, e que potencial é esse né, aí vamos lá, BBS E, que não tem que ter potencial,
tem que ter potência, pelo que aqui para comprar, vamos comprar uma cota, uma ação aqui no caso,
R$ 34, com R$ 32, coloquei a senha, ordem sendo executada, e pronto, agora eu sou dono inclusive
de seguradora, e não para por aí, também inserei banqueiro aqui no Brasil, porque a
empresa que vamos investir, vai ser um grande banco brasileiro, que é banqueiro, não é bancário,
é que bancário trabalha no banco, é banqueiro, é dono do banco, vai ser o Itaú, através da
Etube 4, as suas preferenciais R$ 43,80, o maçã hoje, e pagou em dividendos nos últimos 12 meses,
R$ 3,14, o Itaú, há muito tempo, é um dos bancos mais lucrativos do Brasil, com
R$ 4,50, o Return On Equity, tanto que ano passado, eles bateram um lucro recorde de R$ 46,8 bilhões,
imagina um lucro desse, imagina você tendo 0,1% do Itaú, e eu quero comprar, então investindo aí,
o Itaú vale R$ 485 bilhões, ele tem um número total de ações, de mais de 11 bilhões, e eu vou
comprar o dono de uma dessas ações, então vamos lá, clico aqui, investir, e a partir do momento que
eu me tornar sócio do Itaú, com uma ação que eu estou comprando, eu já vou poder lá na agência,
e ver se o pessoal está trabalhando direitinho, se o gerente está atendendo bem os clientes,
se ele está conseguindo rentabilizar bem o patrimônio da galera, se bem que aí lá vai ter que vender
capitalização, vai ter que vender os produtos deles, mas enfim, que nem sempre é interessante para o
pessoal, porém vamos lá, R$ 44,27, ordem enviada, agora chegou a hora de pegar o restante do
dinheiro e mandar para fora, tirar daqui do Brasil, e aproveitar essa janela do dólar por volta dos
R$ 5, então no dia que estamos gravando esse vídeo está R$ 5,01, porém ontem por exemplo,
deu aquela fisgadinha nos R$ 4,98, poucos dias atrás R$ 4,95, sendo que no final de 2024,
doce de 2025, o dólar passou dos R$ 6,00, nessa hora o pessoal se desesperou com força,
calma lá, estou vendo que meu dinheiro está derretendo, não estava lendo mais nada, e eu não tenho nada lá
fora, e foi correndo para dolarizar, agora que tivemos essa queda, a verdade é que os brasileiros
não estão olhando ainda para isso, mas temos R$ 2,26, ano de eleição, volatilidade, temos uma
bomba fiscal que vai explodir em R$ 2,27, e eu aproveito a melhor oportunidade que existe em cada
país, então aqui nas caixinhas eu posso botar dinheiro, tem caixinha turbo também, aqui na parte
fundo do mobiliário, se não o bank pode ser interessante, porém para investir no exterior,
diretamente fora do Brasil, no no bank não existe essa possibilidade, a corretora que nós
utilizamos para investir fora do Brasil é a Quantifúrio, e vou investir na prática com vocês,
clico aqui, reais brasileiros, clico para depositar, já aparece o QR Code, eu clico aqui para copiar,
clico para colar aqui no meu roxinho, e eu coloco quanto eu quero enviar, eu enviado tudo que sobrou,
R$ 413,84, agora fazendo esse passo a passo, o nosso dinheiro não se encontra mais no Brasil,
o dinheiro já caiu na conta, eu tinha um trocadinho aqui de outra vez que nós investimos, e vamos no
passo a passo, primeiramente eu tenho que converter esses reais para dólares, porque eu vou comprar,
eu vou investir em ativos dolarizados, já está parecendo aqui mais de R$ 83, inclusive o saldo
que eu deixo aqui na Quantifúrio em dólar, tem rendimento, como se fosse uma caixinha como se
fosse um porquinho, rendendo aqui a taxa de euros dos Estados Unidos, eu tenho meu saldo em dólares aqui,
eu vou clicar primeiramente para transferir, que aqui é onde eu saco, onde eu deposito dinheiro,
nessa outra conta de trading é onde eu vou lá, e de fato invisto nos ativos, vou mandar R$ 80,
o que sobra aqui, vai ficar rendendo em dólar, está gostoso, e primeiramente vamos investir em
empresas americanas, porém eu não vou investir em só uma empresa, então eu poderia escolher que
eu quero Apple, que eu quero Amazon, que eu quero Nvidia, eu vou investir em todas elas ao mesmo
tempo através de um ETF que ele é uma cesta de ativos, então eu clico aqui na lupa e vai ser no
ETF Spy, que replica o S&P 500, as 500 maiores empresas dos Estados Unidos, então dentro desse
vídeo nós temos Nvidia, Apple, Microsoft, Amazon, Alphabet, Google, Broadcom, Meta, Facebook,
Instagram, Whatsapp, tem Tesla, tem a empresa do Warren Buffet, tem o total de 500 empresas,
as maiores lá dos Estados Unidos, e saiba o seguinte, eu quero que você do outro lado me
responda, então as 10 maiores empresas do mundo, vocês podem ver aqui o ranking, que 8 delas estão
nos Estados Unidos, somente duas não estão, e ao mesmo tempo que elas estão nos Estados Unidos,
na bolsa americana, elas vendem para o mundo todo, então Nvidia, toda essa corrida de inteligência
artificial, é global, Google, você mesmo, utiliza o Google todos os dias, o YouTube que você está
vendo nesse vídeo aqui é do Google, então os brasileiros dão dinheiro para as empresas americanas,
Apple não precisa nem falar, o meu telefone é iPhone, muita gente tem aqui no Brasil iPhone,
o que a iPad, Microsoft, Windows, desse computador aqui, é dessa forma, a Amazon, assim no Amazon
Prime, compro na Amazon todos os meses, que empresa de tecnologia dessa forma,
é igual a esse aqui, tem no Brasil, como que você vai expor esses setores investindo na bolsa
brasileira, não vai ter, eu mandei 80 dólares para investir, eu vou colocar 40 para comprar aqui,
no ETFs, muito importante, na bolsa brasileira, a acimação do Itaú são 40 reais, você tem
20 reais para investir, uma cota do spy custa mais de 700 dólares, porém eu posso investir
somente 40, e eu estou comprando uma fração de uma ação 0,05, então no exterior você não precisa
comprar uma cota inteira do ETF, você não precisa comprar uma ação inteira, você pode comprar
uma fração e eu já investi mais um pouco aqui no spy, e aqui na QtFury é uma corretora
internacional que você não paga taxa nenhuma, exatamente o preço que está aparecendo na tela,
é o preço que você vai pagar, e além disso, para você que fizer exatamente esse mesmo,
passo a passo, criar sua conta, fazer seu primeiro investimento equivalente a 50 dólares,
porém tem que ser através do link da descrição, colocando o código gêmeos na hora de abrir
sua conta, você vai ganhar uma recompensa em Bitcoin, eu quando criei minha conta antes mesmo
da parceria, ganhei 5 dólares, já o Mateus ganhou 20 dólares, você vai investir assim como eu
aqui pra vocês, e tem o presente aqui, a sua recompensa vai estar lá, e o próximo investimento
vai ser em Bitcoin, então não bem que até tem como investir em Bitcoin, porém lá as taxas são
altas, ainda por cima você não pode sacar pra sua carteira externa caso você queira,
e eu tenho certeza que muitas pessoas agora não querem mais saber de Bitcoin, então quando
estava lá final do ano passado por volta do seu 126 mil dólares, aí todo mundo criou que a Bitcoin
vai subir, as pessoas compram porque está subindo e não por conta dos fundamentos,
então o Bitcoin é uma moeda descentralizada, não depende nenhum banco, não depende nenhum governo,
vão existir no máximo 21 milhões de unidades, sendo que mais de 20 milhões já estão em
circulação, enquanto isso as moedas fiduciárias emitidas por governos, então real,
eles podem emitir cada vez mais, desvalorizando o dinheiro que você já possui, então aqui nós
vamos ver o que é o M2 do real, de uma forma simplificada, é oferta de reais na economia,
quanto mais dinheiro tem em circulação, menos dinheiro que você já tem na carteira, já tem
na conta, passa a valer, e vocês podem ver que pouco antes depois da pandemia, a oferta de dinheiro,
mais que dobrou, é por conta disso que no passado antes da pandemia umquide,
0KM custava menos de 40 mil, hoje custa mais de 80, vamos comprar na prática com vocês,
a gente tem hoje 75 mil dólares, tem uma queda de 2% de ontem pra hoje,
clico em comprar, e vamos colocar os 40 dólares, e eu sei que quando o Bitcoin passar de novo aí
do 100 mil, 200 mil dólares, aí a galera vai querer saber, né? Aí nas nossas lives vai ter
gente perguntando se vale a pena entrar agora ou não, vocês viram que com apenas mil reais nós
conseguimos emprestar dinheiro a juros, virar dono de imóveis, virar dono de grandes empresas aqui no
Brasil, virar dono das 500 maiores empresas dos Estados Unidos, e ainda por cima comprar uma moeda
que não depende nenhum banco ou governo, descentralizada, tudo isso com mil reais na prática com vocês,
pra você utilizar a Quantifury, ainda por cima receber essa recompensa em Bitcoin, link na descrição
e nos vemos no próximo vídeo.